what's going on reject nation we got
some miles morales spider-man game stuff
to look at three different clips here
the first one is an exclusive look at
first
boss no idea who that first boss is the
other one is checking in on miles and
peter so we'll get some peter parker
in here and the last one is exclusive
look at spider cat finally come in here
to the spider verse world of the video
games
maybe we'll get the the venom pigeon
down the road that'd be fun anywho
we're gonna watch all three of these
just back to back and then
uh we'll have a little bit of discussion
afterwards this is all coming from the
channel
game informer excited to check it out
man big fan of this spider-man ps4 game
that new look i
i guess is warming up on me peter parker
from the ps5
let's do this
wow
oh it's going to be rydo isn't it it's
going to be rhino it's got to be rhino
[ __ ] miles had a terrible last encounter
in the previous
game let me get some revenge
even though even though he won last time
technically
cool cool
this is everything i wanted out of paul
[Applause]
giamatti
cool how awesome yeah great
yeah that looked great yeah uh miles
before he had powers had to do a lot of
there's this one level in the other game
where there's a lot of dodging of uh i
had to sneak around rhino
which was actually a really scary part
of the game in my opinion it sounds like
just looking at that it's just fun to
see him having to burst him again
here but this time he's got spider-man
powers all right so then we're gonna
watch
uh checking in on miles and peter in
spider-man miles morales
that sounds like a good idea
oh look at the frost it's snowing
that is beautiful
one of those guys who looked up doctors
in there i think so
could be vulture scorpion
could be someone bigger
like a difference in the swing in
between them that i really enjoyed
because you know like he's still a kid
yeah and you you actually
get that it's it's a little subtle
except in certain moments obviously
but what was great about that was you
can really feel that there's uh
a difference in just their experience
with
web swinging around you know that and
you could you could really pick up on
that in the way they animated it that
was
great they've just got their own gate
and personality now the one we've all
been waiting for
as an owner of four cats i'm excited
to see the exclusive look at spider cat
in spider-man miles morales
danke said the acts blowing up city
definitely needs a spider-man
ship patrol for a while looks like
taylor's bodega was robbed
[Music]
should probably call genki when i get
there yes you should
there's my way in
now for the breaker for real this time
let's get out of here spider-man
it's called spider-man also amen
power restored spider-man
yes
now press circle and make it attack
someone
hey taylor no adam nice for you
oh yeah oh my little cat bad
spiderman
did you have an adventure
[Music]
a heart attack oh yes you did
oh yes you did
[Music]
good work other spider-man
[Laughter]
the hats the light of course
you ready to swing spider cat you two
look great
oh snap yes
oh oh i gotta get one for the cat yes
that's all i've ever wanted
oh oh christmas has come
that was awesome i gotta get a spider
cat mask for all
four of the cats all four of them will
love
and put up with that yeah you know that
you know cats love that
that kind of crap man dads love costumes
wow
whoa it looks like spider cat's a real
true addition in this game baby i'm
excited for that
that's a finishing move right there and
i love that this store owner has a spot
as
you know this cat spider-man who
actually has abilities now but what's
great about
uh you know infusing spider cat into
here having this world realizes you
really feel the celebration and love for
spider-man from the community here
and also you know getting like some
peter parker i was one of the people
when i first saw the very first trailer
i was under the impression that peter
parker was like probably dead or
something like that but i'm glad we're
going to be exploring
a lot of the mentorship a perfect segue
from the last spider-man game and the
way how that ended kicking off this one
and feeling this inexperienced miles
morales
having to really pick up some uh skills
tricks of the trade it's gonna be a
great game man
i mean i keep saying it everyone i think
for the most part believes it
i'm not convinced i need more footage of
spider cats
no i mean this looks super awesome this
makes me want a ps5 right now because
it also looks just like yeah that charm
of being able to
live the spider-man life of like
swinging around but also getting the
engaged story like it's it seems like
the perfect way to bring a comic book to
life and then
be able to have super silly fun with a
spider cat while you're doing that
yeah you know it seems perfect like i
think from just a personal
biased very subjective standpoint spider
cat's my favorite part out of the three
ones we watch just because i'm a big cat
lover at the same time though i think
the most to garner
from what really stood out to me in
terms of like the actual video game
itself
more than the exclusive first boss look
is actually the one with him
and peter swinging together because yes
you're getting the different
demonstrations of the types of web
slinging around and then the
uncoordination but also like the
cockiness of miles
and to me that really shows the
difference in dynamics and personalities
fully
on display here you know because if
you're gonna play spider-man ps4 where
you're
living it as peter parker for majority
of the game and to go into miles morales
you're really going to want to
distinguish between the two other than
just a different look and a couple of
different powers like we all know that
but i think having
a you know a scene where they're
together like and several of those
especially in these mentorship ones will
really put that on display
oh yeah anywho guys what do you think
about the footage what's your favorite
part are you as excited for spider cat
as i am
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell
last but not least let's do a pic
mike pdf15 sent you a message a while
ago
still haven't heard back from you and
now you've landed yourself with a shout
out
where there's nothing to really go off
of so let's start with this thank you so
much for being part of our patreon page
buddy
really appreciate you now mike what does
that stand for
m ooh for magnificent i
for imaginative
k for killer looks
and e for endoplasmic
i know what that means definitely thanks
for being part of our patreon page mike
appreciate it hopefully we get a message
back soon love you bud
and send it as a pdf
[Music]